as the CEO of the organization I'm glad
to say we don't have a lot of times when
the board has been in a dysfunctional
mode but when that does happen I find
the best thing to do is to use board
members as peers to help each other get
to where they need to be even as the
head of the organization that's expected
to know the most about what's going on
with it sometimes the hard work has to
be done by a peer asking a peer to step
up in a different way very importantly
the first and most important thing is to
document it if you can document what's
happened and then share that with say
another board member or hopefully two or
three then as a group you can come up
with a strategy to present to the CEO
and make sure that number one the CEO
understands what's going on perhaps they
have a different view of it perhaps they
this is a big donor and there's
inefficiencies because a big donor wants
tandem and certain things those are all
trade offs that one makes I would never
leave a board just because of individual
problems I would actually hope to find
ways to work through these kinds of
situations with other board members and
ultimately in discussion with the CEO
both culture is a huge issue and
sometimes it can only be altered by a
sufficient changeover in the number of
people on the board there has to be new
blood if the board is largely
dysfunctional first of all the the
executive director has to bear
responsibility for that what what has
she what has he or she done that has
allowed that to come about what is the
board chair in doing that has allowed
that to come about is that the choice of
people we've been working with we have
brought onto the board is it or is it
the way we have plans and meetings is it
a lack of engagement on the part of the
chair and the key office bearers so you
need to look at your succession planning
for people coming onto the board the
orientation that they receive as they
come onto the board
are you really doing everything you can
to have made that person feel part of
the organization and really committed to
its progress
board members are volunteers right in
nonprofits and so it really is indirect
influence right I mean ultimately a
board could you know deselect somebody I
suppose who's not working out very well
but usually the reason the persons on
the board was at some point they
actually had a real commitment in
alignment with the vision and
potentially could continue to be an
advocate and an ambassador for the
organization so you usually don't want
to burn bridges even if somebody's not
working out as a board member and so
trying to manage the relationship and
provide a face-saving way for the
organization or for the board and that
individual to part ways is usually both
the right approach